be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is be a little
bit dangerous and have a discussion on
Superman 1 million the downside or I
guess the difficult part of this is that
Superman 1 million only has about five
or six appearances in the entirety of DC
Comics and so what we're going to have
to do is both rely on a bit of existing
information as well as draw and a source
that I found from comic vine which
actually goes as far as to analyze
Superman 1 million in the eyes of fans
versus how he actually exists using
information that was provided in the
comics so Superman 1 million who's
oftentimes referred to as Superman prime
by existing DC fans first appeared in
the larger DC 1 million story line in
1998 and was created by Grant Morrison
to sidetrack for a second during an
interview with C Court an organization
designed to promote comics as an art
form and pop culture influenced Grant
Morrison had stated that with the revamp
JL a title seeing such a massive surge
of popularity owing to the team
reforming with this original lineup for
the first time and the post-crisis
continuity DC elected to allow Morrison
to take the reins on the new JLA titles
first line wide crossover centering on a
version of the Justice League from the
850 third century operating under the
moniker of the Justice League in alpha
the team's lineup consisted of a
veritable mishmash of characters who had
been introduced for radical II during
Morrison's time on the JLA title and
included the future versions of Batman
Superman Wonder Woman and Aquaman
depicting Justice Legion alpha as one of
a multitude of universal Justice League
teams with each patrolling their own
solar systems after humanity entered a
utopian age and colonized the universe
Justice Legion alpha functioned as the
top team and consisted of its most
capable and brightest superheroes who
imbue the very essence of what it meant
to be a member of the Justice League
traveling into the past to recruit the
original Justice League as part of their
celebration the store revealed that the
celebration itself was rooted in the
fact that the present-day Superman had
lived well into the future and existed
in the 850 third century but it moved
his fortress of solitude from Earth to
the center of the Sun referred to as
Superman prime in an effort to
distinguish him as the original Superman
and how he spent the last 15
thousand years within the heart of Earth
star the expected emergence of Superman
prime has given way to the Justice
League in alpha and the rest of the
Universal Justice League teams to visit
and bring a litany of heroes from across
both time and space ridden as an in
comic reference to the legacy of the
Justice League and that the various
actions of Batman and others have
guaranteed their future successors who
would carry on the mantle of humanity's
protectors where the story would go on
to see two separate events unfolding in
both the past and the present
Superman prime remained almost entirely
absent instead the events emphasized the
Justice League and Justice Legion alpha
working in unison to defeat both the
past and present iterations of the
immortal villain Vandal Savage as well
as the artificial star Solaris who had
looked to destroy Superman prime prior
to his emergence while Morrison had
injected a ton of new information into
the DC landscape by introducing solarz
as a retcon villain of Superman as well
as establishing the Superman dynasty
regarding those members of the Superman
bloodline who took up the mantle after
Prime's retirement on the whole the
story was relatively easy to follow and
that the present-day Vandal Savage
looked at detonate a nuclear bomb and
send the world into chaos while his
future counterpart alongside Solaris
infected humanity and his computers with
a virus under the hopes that the
distraction would not only lead to
humanity's downfall through chaos the
civil war but would leave the landscape
open for Superman Prime's destruction
however where Morrison's riding would
see both iterations of Vandal Savage
defeated and solarz destroyed by the now
emerging Superman prime most of
Superman's powers and feats went
entirely unexplained as they've been
presented by fans through various forums
and websites while common thought and
existing fanfare has given way to the
notion that Superman one-million
possesses power on a scale hitherto
unrivaled by any of Earth's heroes and
most of DC's gods in the weeks leading
up to the launch of DC's conversions
user mystic medev had posted an article
to Comic Vine analyzing Superman 1
million and the various facets of its
perceived power while you will find the
article in the description for more
detailed analysis the argument produced
and supported by mystic medev
established that most all of Superman 1
million powers including reality
manipulation and time manipulation are
essentially misnomers with this actual
feats falling between the cracks
referencing the statements of Kyle
Rayner who had fought alongside both the
Justice League and Jess
Allegiant alpha in the future the first
argument produced by Superman 1 million
fans was that he possessed the power to
create Lois Lane on his own however in
the comic itself and Kyle Weiner had
stated that lick some little pig a
version of Superman from the 5th
dimension with the same powers as mr.
Mixel pedelec had actually created Lois
as part of his tribute to the legacy
created by Superman prime regarding the
recreation of Krypton at the end of DC 1
million where many fans attribute this
to Superman pran himself the recreation
of Krypton actually came by way of our
man from the 850 3rd century who used
the war GOG a source of energy
not unlike Marvel's cosmic cube which
allows its wielder to bend space and
time permitting our man and the Justice
League to recreate Krypton and his
inhabitants including Superman's
biological parents
all of whom retain their memories prior
to their deaths finally and is one of
the most cited instances of his powers
most fans looked at the argument the
Superman one-million succeeded in
entering the source which functions as
the energy and power of God within the
DC landscape however with Kyle Rayner
simply stating the Superman 1 million
had stood before the gates of heaven
this statement as is presented in both
the comics and this coming by an article
argue that because DC actually contains
heaven as a wholly different place with
its own access gates the idea of
Superman travelling into heaven had been
misinterpreted with that
misinterpretation being carried on
throughout the comic community now while
these arguments and others do present a
compelling case something to also take
note of here is that the entirety of
this information on the perception of
Superman's powers comes from the words
of Kyle Rayner and addition of this
because Grant Morrison's stories have a
knack for commentaries within the comics
themselves the legitimate case could be
made the calibrator isn't actually able
to fully grasp the capabilities of
Superman 1 million and that Superman 1
million himself had actually entered the
source and gained a litany of new powers
and truth aside from works or direct
answers written by Morrison himself the
actual presentable evidence of what
Superman 1 million is capable of is
completely up for speculation by both
existing and prospective fans of his
character with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
yeah for a guy that appeared at only 5
issues I don't think we did that bad
but uh I'll catch you guys later please